alors c'est les six ans s'est vite c'est
les six ans également de tpm paix où
vous a fait un petit récap mêmes lolo
bats toi tu fais partie de ces huit donc
tu vas pour lui dire tu vas prendre à
vous dire ce que tu penses de la chaîne
tnt les patrons de ces mythes non ils
sont très sympas s'arrête au ces le le
patron le plus sympa que je connaisse
pas ce que je fais partie d'une
génération je commence à vieillir
non il est patron de chaîne sont plus
jeunes que moi maintenant et j'ai toute
ma carrière j'ai vu que des vieux cons
incompétent mais maintenant je rencontre
des gens sympas ces nouveaux cancers est
été heureux sur s'évitant mais oui très
mais véronique je sais pas non plus
regarder 1-4 là vous allez revoir plein
de choses à vous faire du bien regarder
il y as tout pile six ans le 8 octobre
2012 touche pas à mon poste se démarquer
sur l'a8
première ce soir à l'occasion du mille
cent soixante dix septième numéro de tpm
paix sur l'a8
retour sur six années de succès et si le
taux de chô est devenu un véritable
phénomène c'est avant tout grâce au
talent incontestable mais parfois
incompréhensibles de son chef
d'orchestre mais tmp en six ans c'est
aussi 1092 invités et de l'art star en
veux tu en voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà des énormes stars enfin presque
toujours
moi alors
il milla
281 chroniqueurs se sont assis autour de
la table des chroniqueurs pointu classe
et élégant la recette du succès c'est
sans doute cet humour affilée toujours
tourné vers la subtilité et touche à ton
cul tu auras des verrues toi
non on déconne parce qu'en vrai la dnt
pmp c'est surtout ça ont confirmé que ça
vous dérange pas de le voir mon cul ça
en résumé si l'on tpm pc une culotte
et plus de 2500 heures de direct sur
l'a8 avec les surprises
[Applaudissements]
de la musique de la danse et surtout
beaucoup de barca
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors encore joyeuse hanoune
anniversaire
d'avoir été aussi dallas depuis six ans
sans révéler vous vous rendez compte
bon on est content mille cent soixante
dix septième émission mais enfin c ou
alors je vous rappelle on avait débarqué
ya six ans et c'était après qu'ils ont
alors directeur du pôle flux du groupe
canal+ qu' on est dans le groupe canal+
voilà à non pas ça on va pas la bonne
photo web est élu une autre photo quand
même là alors et donc le set up pour la
toute première émission le lancement
était un peu captage en eau il a remis à
ces instructions pain grillé tromper si
bon que ça les chiens de regarder
c'était une cata le lancement de ces
huit regarde deux boutons qu'on va lever
et après ce sera parti pour des vite il
nous reste maintenant 20 secondes c'est
vrai que le moment était émouvant
c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
que je fais ça moi j'ai l'impression que
je j'ai l'impression que je vais faire
décoller un avion
j'ai l'impression que c'est pas nous
lasser par un animateur c'est un pilote
de ligne
attention l'état dit seconde voiture le
décompte ensemble c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
ta ta ta ta ta